hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast particle counters must
now be calibrated with ISO to 1 501 -
for your instruments comply presented by
Jo get see the life science application
manager assessment culture life sciences
PCC particle counting and
characterization we are excited to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
Beckman Coulter life sciences Beckman
Coulter serves customers in two segments
diagnostics and life sciences the
company develops manufactures and
markets products that simplify automate
and innovate complex biomedical testing
more than 275 thousand Beckman culture
systems operate in both diagnostics and
life science laboratories on seven
continents scientists use Beckman
cultures life science research
instruments to study complex biological
problems including causes of disease and
potential new therapies or drugs to
learn more about Bethlem culture life
sciences please visit
www.meliar.com/mpanel.htm the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on your screen
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located in the lower
right and finally if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or you can use the Q&A button to let us
know that you're having a problem thank
you now I'd like to introduce Joe Getty
Joe has
been involved with the particle counting
industry since 1984 first joining net1
as an electronic design engineer Joe has
been involved in both airborne and
liquid particle counter design as well
as multi sensor systems for facility
monitoring systems has also been
involved in various standards involving
particle counting in air and liquids
Joe is part of the TC 209 wg1 revision
group on the main global cleanroom
certification standard ISO one four six
four four - one and two one of the two
Americans on the committee is also
involved with the ISO TC 24 / sv for
committees related to use and
calibration of various particle counting
and characterization instruments recent
years Joe has presented information
seminars in Asia Europe and South
America on particle counting and
numerous associated topics please join
me in welcoming Joe I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you Judy
good morning
and thank you for joining us and we bye
to fall today's talk with questions I'm
sure the people have various concerns
questions about both the ISO 21 501 as
well as a 14 644 so happy to be able to
speak about that and address that all
those concerns hopefully get all the
questions answered at the end so again
I've been involved with some of the
various standards and there's always
questions as new standards are brought
forward and none of them are ever quite
perfect but certainly they have an
effect on us and it's good to be able to
have the chance to have dialogue about
it so briefly today's agenda is to look
at the history of 14 644 as a starting
document just briefly and then to look
at the differences in the way these
documents are applied to address both
the issues of cleanroom classification
as well as the more perhaps daily or
weekly tasks
of monitoring follow that with a review
of the recent changes in the 14 644
document that occurred in this last year
was effective in December and to look at
the demands that relate to 21 501 - for
calibration for airborne counters not to
go into it in great detail but to kind
of address that and to understand the
impact or effect of that to look at the
benefits and of course at the end to be
able to have some further dialogue in
that so the main thing two main items to
consider realizes at 14 644 now does
references ISO 21 501 - 4 method which
has been around for a number of years
actually goes back to 2007 so it itself
is not new it's just the interconnection
between 14 644 and the 21 501
calibration non-oil counters were
originally designed to meet 21 501
although most of the ones made in the
last five years or so would and also to
realize that due to damage or misuse or
age particle counters even if they were
originally designed and produced to meet
the standard may not stay within the
boundaries of the calibration standard
limits throughout their lifetime so it's
a life cycle process for that and to
realize that 21 501 itself is also being
reviewed and looked at don't expect
major changes but that also will be
forthcoming in the next one to two years
so the main thing now is just to realize
that 21 final one has its impact if
you're in a regulated industry it might
be important and to verify that your
current equipment does meet that and/or
make plans by budgeting and so forth to
bring your equipment up to that level if
it's needed
so just a little background on 14 644 I
expect most of the people listening in
or probably familiar with it but just to
touch on it started back before 1999
previous to that most most nations had
some form of a cleanroom standard but
that made it of course difficult to
communicate internationally about
various needs that might be required for
a given corporation or application so in
1999 the ISO 14 6 44 document was put
forward and we're focusing in this
discussion just on the first two
segments of it which deal with the
cleanliness of air related to particles
cleaners can mean many things to people
in terms of or their needs certainly
particles have been the predominant
concern but there's certainly some
industries that are focused on various
kinds of chemicals in the air or
chemicals on surfaces and so forth today
though we're just focusing on these two
segments that speak to the cleanliness
in terms of particles in the air one
thing it's important to realize about
ISO 14 644 is it it really is addressing
all industries it does not think about
the actual application or use so we're
looking at a document here that isn't
focused for example on GM PS or isn't
focused on aerospace or isn't focused on
semiconductor it just speaks to the
needs of someone who has a very clean
space at different levels and method to
allow them to assess that and a
consistent basis so it's as most
standards are designed basically you put
forward a method you talk about perhaps
tools or instruments needed to execute
the method and the intent then is that
anyone can follow that procedure use the
correct instruments or tools and come up
with the same final analysis the whole
concept if you would say buying behind
any standard but again this is something
that applies to all industries not
specifically to anyone
as I mentioned I saw 14 6:44 today
consists of many parts up to 15 of them
at the moment and that speaks to
cleanliness in various forms again we're
focused just on the first two sections
related to particles in the air one of
the things that is often very confusing
it is important to realize a distinction
is it the instruments that are used for
monitoring airborne particulate are
really used in two different ways to
different intentions even though you're
using the same box the same instrument
it really follows the need to look both
at the formal classification effort as
well as the more frequent perhaps daily
or even continuous monitoring to assure
that the room stays not in compliance
with the standard but rather up to the
level of quality needed for a particular
procedure or process so these are two
different approaches and people often
confused and apply the classification
document to monitoring or for the Sun
occasionally vice-versa but it's
important to realize you do have two
different needs addressed by this type
of instrument so when we look at that if
we look at the classification effort for
example to start it's something that's a
formal study it's done every six months
or perhaps once a year number of
positions sample volume and format so
forth are all dictated within the
standard and there's a single ultimate
pass/fail limit for the classification
you either have an ISO five at at point
five microns or you don't
based on a limit for that particular
size and that particular classification
one of the important things to realize
in this called philosophical distinction
between classification and monitoring is
the assumption in classification that
the room or zone is reasonably
consistent in terms of particle
concentration that it's reasonably
homogeneous anywhere you go you get more
or less the same reading not exactly by
any means but reasonably close anywhere
you go so it is assuming somewhat
uniform
distribution when we contrast that to
the task of monitoring you see something
that's much more frequent you're really
trying to assess my day to day or week
to week appropriate level that's in that
zone or room there there are no formulas
related to monitoring you don't have a
statistical methodology that relates to
that and often you end up with two
different limits you have alert inaction
in some industries looking for maybe
some general consistency or trending
information or perhaps even control and
very high-risk operations so the reports
end up then in some quick form for
understanding maybe a quick control
chart some kind of a method that allows
you to very rapidly assess the
appropriateness for your task and
monitoring really looks at each position
uniquely you might have two positions in
the same general classification of a
room in ISO five room as an example that
have unique alert in action values due
to the type of process or the sense of
risk associated with that particular
position so that's one of the key
differences is in monitoring we're
looking at the each point as a unique
entity so again back to the sense of
differences the focus of assessment
classification is a rumor the zone and
for monitoring we're really making sure
each point stands on the merits needed
for the performance of a task or a
particular procedure so let's focus
first on this task of classification
which is what the 14 6:44 document
points to and its fundamental purpose or
purposes you could say are two twofold
really one is it gives us a common
language we can talk about an ISO class
five or an ISO class two or an ISO class
seven room pretty much around the world
people have an understanding what level
of type of room that is what type of
garments will be new
did to maintain that room so it gives us
common language it's a first point the
second is it gives us a method of
statistical method to evaluate that room
and assess its readiness to carry out
whatever task we've done again we aren't
specific to an industry in this document
so you might be putting a satellite
together in a very large high room you
might be putting drugs into into vials
or ampules you might be doing surgery
this document doesn't think about that
it just says here's a way to assess it
without taking 100% of the air out of
the room and that's where the
statistical method comes in we don't
know with a hundred percent certainty
what the room classification is at that
moment in time so we're if we're going
to take a sampling of it then the
question arises well how many places and
how much air at each point so that's
really the fundamental purpose
underlying the standard giving a
consistent statistical method everyone
could apply and evaluate an area and say
is it appropriate for the task I have
planned for that room in the standard
there are nine different classes of
rooms I so one through I so nine going
from very clean at ISO one two not very
clean at all in ISO nine most operations
tend to be in the range from five to
eight but not always depends on the
particular type of Industry and Method
certainly semiconductor industry
utilizes ISO to need nicer one at times
very demanding but needed for that
particular type of operation to have
success to have high yield in the case
of semiconductor operations it also
outlines six different sizes to be used
for the evaluation so at the top here we
have a listing of these size of six
sizes any one of which or several of
could be used to classify depending on
the process at hand
so these sizes can be used as needed for
describing a certain process so that
standard has been in existence and been
used by most industry since the 1999
initial release
finally after a number of years in
December of 2015 some revisions were put
forward and published so the document is
now a 2015 document so what what changed
well in a sense not a tremendous amount
it's important with most standards not
to make radical differences unless for
some reason the methods or technologies
have shifted substantially so you
wouldn't say that it made big
differences but it did make a few and I
want to just briefly touch on those as
we discussed this and its relationship
to 21 501 so some things as I said
change there's really two major ones
that I'll address shortly to it so the
first thing is you know the requirement
that was there originally to address the
upper confidence limit specific methods
when you are sampling very few positions
less than 10 positions is has been
withdrawn in the 2015 edition the
frequencies of retesting used to be
stated as six months if it was ISO five
or cleaner twelve months for ISO six
seven eight nine that's no longer
specified by class the labeling of the
class note that didn't change we still
have ISO one through ISO nine
calibration of equipment there is a
slight difference always there was a
need to calibrate equipment that was
standard stated in 1999 version now it
points to a specific method known as ISO
21 501 - for the basic statistical side
of things in the sample volume and time
didn't change however the minimum number
of the locations did and so we'll
address that and again this was to put
the standard on a slightly better
statistical footing where we could see
at the end of the assessment data that
gave us a 95 percent confidence that we
met the room classification so again the
the limits for the ISIL changed as we'll
see and the general classifications
still the same that's the same the basic
need here for the sizes no change with
that what we do see though or a couple
of changes in the outline point of the
table where we had very small number
statistically and ran into issues in
terms of the successful sampling of
those and using a statistical limit
based on extremely small number so let's
focus on the two the main items the
minimum number of locations in the
calibration of equipment these are
really the ones that impact people most
so a minimal number of locations let's
look at that previously it was a simple
kind of mathematical calculation based
on the area of the room or so it might
be an isolator we're talking about not a
whole room but a box a laminar airflow
bench whatever the zone of interest is
we would measure that and get a value in
square meters and then take the square
root of that area if it wasn't a whole
number we increased it slightly so if we
had for example a 20 square meter area
we take the square root of that and say
well that's not exactly between 4 & 5 so
we bump up to 5 and that would define
the minimum number of locations for
calling that area by ISO code as we
looked at that from the statistical side
in the group we finally determined that
really wasn't quite sufficient it gave
us maybe 80 odd percent confidence but
really not the 95 percent that we really
were trying to achieve so with the help
of
some consultants and statistics one from
Denmark one from Japan and other from
the US it was determined that we need to
increase that and we really needed
something more like a chart in order to
carry out that improvement in this
district or reliability so in the
current document there is this chart and
I realize in my presentation here it's
quite a small numbers but if you look at
the this you can see to the left we have
a column that references the square
meters still so we're still speaking
about area based in square meters and
for any particular point in the column
you you look at your number and find out
if it is exactly that if it's not if
it's in between then you take the next
highest one and from that then we drive
a minimum number of sample locations so
a little bit of the same process just
based on a chart so if we look at the
example that's highlighted where we had
36 square meters previously when we
would use a earlier method of taking the
square root that would have yield at a
minimum of 6 in today's chart that value
is now seen to be 9 so it's an increase
not substantial it's not doubling but it
is an increase in almost all cases to
some extent for the number of minimum
number of positions and again this is
based on the need to try to get to a 95%
confidence value for the determination
so again a statistical method we want
high confidence that's set to target to
a 95% confidence the second major change
and really at the heart of today's
conversation is about the calibration
method the ISO 21 501 - for one that
people aren't as familiar with generally
and certainly has come to the fore in
this overall commentary about the
changes to the ISO 14 6 44 document and
again
obviously the statement in the document
that 14 644 documents said you need to
have a calibrated particle counter to
execute the method that's great but
there were many different types of
calibration methodologies globally or
even within a given country you'd find
different variations and that led to a
fair bit of inconsistency well a
standard ideally should be very
consistent we should find the same
results based on the method and the
instruments used so that it in the sense
gives us a reliable and consistent
information as a standard so the
committee adopted a known and specific
method 21500 1-4 and again this has been
around since 2007 so it's new in 1460 44
but not a new method so previously most
people did at least a basic calibration
when they talked about calibrating the
particle counters they checked the size
they checked a false count rate that is
could at zero count correctly if had
very clean air check the flow rate
sample time make sure that all that was
known so that we can evaluate particle
counts per volume per cubic foot in some
cases per cubic meter more often today
so basically bration gave us assurance
that the instrument could carry out that
task what we did with 21500 1-4 is
certainly those basic tasks but also
involving a couple of other further
tests counting efficiency in particular
in that is used to evaluate the
consistency of the instrument over its
lifetime as well as the reproducibility
or difference between instruments that
might be used for this method so based
and using that standard we gained an
improved accuracy of count repeatability
over the lifetime of the instrument
these instruments typically will last
710 I've seen even 15-year use of these
instruments and we'd like to know where
that lifetime that we're still getting
reliable information from it so it's
helping us achieve that it's helping us
achieve better unit
reproducibility so counter a encounter
be give us fundamentally the same
results as we sample in an air one of
the challenges always with particle
counters in in the open air is they
never sampled the same sample between
two instruments we can't pass in series
a sample through instrument a and in
same exact sample to instrument B
there's always that bit of challenge
that the air that we sample is never
precisely the same for the two but we'd
like the instruments if we could force
them to sample the same air
concentrations to really read the same
and that's part of the effort in this
counting efficiency step of this method
that is achieved so we get better
consistent performance out the life
throughout the lifetime and it ties us
into a single method pretty much
globally for calibration and whether or
not you're in a regulated industry and
using the GMP the the good manufacturing
practice methods in life sciences and
pharmaceutical or biopharma it helps
bring that consistency again to the
document and to the daily use so both in
terms of classification and in
monitoring so also I can mention briefly
that 14 644 - to the companion document
was also revised and it's focused on
monitoring so - one focuses on
classification - - focused on monitoring
I'm going to touch on that very briefly
here just because again it does relate
to our discussion today
and this is not again a prescriptive or
formula based document in - to
monitoring occurs in thousand different
ways in all the various industries so
it's impossible to really put together a
standard that describes a method however
what 14 644 - - speaks - is you need to
look at in terms of monitoring the
various needs
to put together a plan we need to
approve it we need to execute it so all
those are discussions that are made in
this - - speaking to a continued
performance of an area appropriate for
the task B via the you're doing surgery
or assembling satellite even painting a
car is done under 30 clean conditions
not nearly as clean though as
semiconductor might be or as
pharmaceutical but all these are various
uses it could be seen and we want to
know day to day or week to week that
we're still okay in terms of our
cleanliness in particle concentration so
basically this is focused on something a
little different than classification
this is focused on giving us a
continuing flow of data over time now
that might be a weekly or monthly basis
it might not be so frequent it could be
though second-by-second but somehow it
looks at this an appropriate time
interval as opposed to classification
which is a event that happens once every
six months or once a year more commonly
so do we know each day or each week that
we're still within the boundaries we
seek for our process environment and
this is what monitoring does in this
framework then we look at the aspect of
creating executing maintaining a plan
and that's pretty familiar to most
people working in the pharmaceutical
farm environment and we do see though an
interesting reference or increased
reference to risk in this document for
any industry so we're talking about do
we understand if we don't monitor or
mantra less frequently do we open
ourselves to greater risk for our
particular process so it has some
discussion of that as well as looking at
the methods to analyze the data so
fundamentally one of the important parts
as I mentioned in this discussion of
risk is it some industries are more
focused on that
others but again being an industry
neutral environment in the ISIL document
we're not looking at a given environment
of a given industry but always whatever
you're doing you see certain level of
risk you say well I'm painting my car
and or I'm doing the surgery and I'm
trying to do it in a specific type of
environment or room if I lose control of
that what is my risk for failing in my
particular process and in this document
though we do mention that yes there
could be some regulatory agencies that
have different methods so we'll touch
briefly as we finish this talk about the
GMP documents the annex one and so forth
that many people in the lot of
pharmaceutical industries need to
address so it says there might be some
other things and even supersede this
there's a general discussion of
monitoring and things to consider think
about and plan for but there may be
other methods and controls depending on
your type of industry there's some
various council in here thinking about
the things that can affect particle
counts in a room the airflow the number
of people and so forth there is also the
council that considered to go back and
review a plan so there should be some
kind of a review on a periodic basis
maybe once a year maybe every two years
to look at the plan you put forward and
assess is it's still appropriate do any
more do I have more people in the room
and I changed my limits try and a fewer
people will have I added to process
those things should be considered in
monitoring it shouldn't be a fixed
document that was issued ten years ago
and has never been looked at again or
changed because in many cases processes
and technologies change and we need to
assess that on occasion maybe the limits
were set too high maybe there weren't
enough places done at the time whatever
it might be it should be reviewed it
should be a living document
again in 14 6:44 - - as well as in 14
644 - 1 there were is a reference as
monitoring that airborne particle
counters should be calibrated following
ISO 21 501 - 4 so that reference shows
up in both these documents both the one
for classification - 1 in this document
for monitoring - 2 I want to call
attention to those who might not be so
familiar with the warning levels and
settings to a annex that is as they say
informative which means it's gets
guidance it's council it's not mandatory
by any means but to realize that when
you deal with pressure differential as
well as airborne particle counts often
you need to think about your warning
limits in a different way because both
for pressure differential and for
airborne particle counts you have
instances where there's elevated or
notable changes but yet it's part of the
normal activity for example in pressure
differential when you open a door in a
room the pressure is definitely going to
change be it a positive negative one for
the short term that the doors open and
then ideally it returns back to the
previous level and you don't want an
alarm to occur no significant change in
pressure same might be true when you
consider airborne particle counts in a
certain region an activity might carry
on increase the particle count level
momentarily but it's part of the normal
process so it's important as you think
about a monitoring plan and try to
establish any form of warning levels
whether you call them alert in action or
anything different to make sure it
references what is normal for process in
the engine you really need to spend time
understanding the process in order to
set these limits because particle counts
and pressure differential really are
different style of data set you could
say compared to for example temperature
humidity in most rooms
those are pretty steady and there could
say that they have an average value plus
or minus a small amount plus or minus 5%
or something like that particle counts
and pressure differential have more
Changez so as you said alert and alarm
levels you need to think about that
reality of that particular type of data
that you're working with how does it
relate to annex 1 commonly used in
pharmaceutical by pharmaceutical and
both the European and the more global
pics documents have an annex one that
ties to the high-risk production of
storoe medicines and how does it how
does this change in 14 644 - one effect
that well in changing 14 644 - 1 + - 2
we didn't change the GMP document there
totally distinct and separate entities
but ISO 14 644 - 1 is referenced in the
annex as a document that sets forward
the number of physicians and other
aspects of verifying that a room which
in that document would be called then
grade A or grade B grade C grade D not
ISIL but upgrade designation wooden
would still be classified and be
monitored in an appropriate way so it
ties these two documents together in
that way so again back to it the first
as we mentioned before minimum number of
sample locations has increased and it
uses this chart so when you're thinking
about how many positions do I need to
classify my grade a zone this then has
the impact of increasing in most cases
the number of positions which you must
monitor to verify and say yes I have a
grade a zone you're not calling it ISO
you're calling a grade A and that means
something different and that's fine you
don't have to have a room always
classified by ISO that's it's you know
again it's industry neutral whereas
something like annex 1 is very specific
to an industry in a process but it
points back to this so for example again
if you had that 36 metre square room
previously you would do 6 positions for
your classification effort to call a
grade a now you need to do
nine positions specific calibration
method then is also triggered by that
reference to the 14 644 - one and - - so
when we look at this overall in terms of
these changes for 14 644 they did take
effect in late 2015
for most areas additional sampling
points will be required that means in
some times then additional cost in terms
of sampling and recording and analyzing
the data but you end up with better data
you end up with higher confidence the
room performance needed some of the new
instrument designs can help mitigate
that impact of extra sample points
needed extra time needed in many
industries so we could look at that and
say well can we can we do something with
today's technology that helps us out
just like our cell phones are much more
much more practical and useful than the
previous of wire connected phones in our
lives so in that same way technology
here can help us streamline workflows
make the organization of how you do the
classification or monitoring much more
consistent there are software wizards in
many cases to guide classification
effort and to make sure the proper
number of positions are taken and we
also have our flow rates available now
so that this amount of sampling for
example for grade a where you need to
take a full cubic meter can be reduced
to 20 minutes or 10 minutes rather than
35 minutes so as various things that can
help happen with improved
instrumentation today so again if we
take a moment and we look at the
monitoring side of this and
classification these are really calling
forward to different documents we talk
about classification we talk about 14
644 - 1 or we talk about annex 1 if
we're driven by the designation of grade
a b c d when we monitor it's really your
own company's standard operating
procedure that defines the monitoring
process there isn't a document that
specifically
for formulas that's in classification
true but it's not in monitoring and so
again just realize it you don't want to
take classification methodology for
minimum number of points for example and
apply it to monitoring in most cases
monitoring involves really one or two
critical points in an area or zone not
six or nine just depends on the type of
operation
so again monitoring is a way to
understand that your control of risk in
your operation is appropriate that you
have enough information to say I've
tried to control my risk as well as
possible regarding any particular
contamination from particles or any
effect in my process due to airborne
particles so just briefly on the
particle counter we look at this
particular instrument and what it does
and this goes to the classification side
of it now getting to look at the 21 501
document in particular basically a
particle counter uses bright light in a
mode known as like light scattering to
detect particles so we have a beam of
light today H typically laser diode and
we pass particles through that as a
particle what gets into the beam it
scatters light from that information we
understand a an event occurred and be
the by the amount of light scattered we
have an idea of the size of the particle
and this happens very very quickly
within actually milliseconds as that
particle moves through the beam this
information is passed forward and so we
count in real time that's one of the
advantages of this particular type of
technology is we have very quickly a
picture of our environment in terms of
particles in the air and that it is or
is not appropriate to the task at hand
well how do we know it's seeing
particles of a certain size how do we
evaluate that with what form of tests
and so forth do we use to both design to
and to use this type of instrument well
that's where the calibration document
comes in
and again 21500 1-4 as an international
document gives us a good base to
establish a method and in order to
calibrate these we can't just grab air
out of particles out of the air rather
we use very well sized particles these
are usually PSL or polystyrene latex
spheres that have been aerosolized put
out into the air and even though they're
very very tightly controlled they do
have some deviation standard deviation
about it they're almost perfect but not
absolutely perfect so you find particles
from jsr or from the american thermo
scientific waste we do a commonly
available and these are concentrations
are very very precise but slightly
varying particles and the particle
counter then samples is that they're
either aerosolize introduced one size at
a time in most cases and we evolve a
calibration curve or response of the
instrument to known sizes of particles
so then we create this type of curve
based on the information we have from
each of the sizes we might use for
example 0.3 0.5 sized particle or 1 5
often they're not exactly those sizes
but they're close so we might then
develop a curve based on that type of
information and we know then the
performance of the instrument and of
course what we want to do is not just
know it at this moment we'd like to over
its lifetime know that it's still
appropriate so that's what 21 501
calibration is about and that helps us
improve the consistency for various
regulated interest industries in
particular the pharmaceutical which
again is the GMP the Good Manufacturing
Practice documents so from Europe for
the FDA picks they all look to this type
of method
no with some assurance that these
instruments do perform correctly and so
you'll often find regulators asking for
calibration documents and now they're
going to expect that those would meet or
show a reference to 21 501 - for not
instantly
I think regulators even though they are
very demanding realize that it takes an
industry some time to come Indus to
accordance with changes in the standards
so they're expecting this and they
expect if you don't have currently
satisfactory performance of the
instruments that you have a plan in
place to get there at some reasonable
point in time next year maybe it's a
matter of budget of course for a lot of
instrumentation next year you've got
this plan in place to get the
instruments upgraded so that they will
meet the calibration standards so again
we look at the old methods or even
commonly simple methods of calibration
compared to 21 501 and we see that
there's more tests involved either in
the design in the production or in the
use at the end-user site that they meet
these various aspects of it and
typically these calibrations are done
once a year however in some industries
many of the life-science the
biopharmaceutical industries they look
to do this every six months because
again their sense of risk is different
than other industries you may have a
high sense of risk and you want to know
your measuring instrument is always
known to be in operation correctly
through calibration so what do we look
for when we do this well we'll certainly
we look to volume because we are talking
about particles per unit volume per
cubic meter per cubic foot whatever the
measurement volume might be or
referenced we want to know that and
typically most of these instruments
operate in a time mode so we know the
flow we verify that in the part of
calibration we know the time period
therefore we can speak to a given volume
we'd say yes we know that
we have a certain volume sampled and
therefore when we count particles we can
reference that volume and understand
particles per volume resolution is
another aspect we want to know about
particle sizes we have particle
restrictions we say oh we want to know
that we're within limits to have no more
than you know a certain number of
particles per size or larger these
instruments are normally set up in
what's known as cumulative mode they
talk about a size and larger 0.5 micron
and larger 5 micron and larger 0.1
micron and larger so we want to know
that they're correctly sized so we go a
conductive resolution test and
resolution is fundamentally telling us
that one size level is not encroaching
on another that we can understand how
well we can define particles that are
certain size in the air and of course in
beginning we do this with test particles
that are exactly a known size that's
helpful but we have to realize that
we're trying to make sure that's correct
counting efficiency is probably the
major test that's changed or added in
for most people and we're trying to
control the biggest variability in the
particle in between two different
particle counters and we also want to
know of course over its lifetime it's
consistently giving us good results
counting efficiency can help the test is
a little bit more involved and you have
to have some kind of a reference
standard instrument so this can be done
on-site me companies have
instrumentation calibrated on-site but
it means that the technician brings more
equipment in takes a little longer to
verify counting efficiencies within the
limits under 21 5 or 1-4 what are those
limits well we talked about counting
efficiency we're trying to do is
understand that exactly known level of
particles going in to the inlet shows up
on the display or the report print over
the electronic record what you think
would be all ok that's pretty
straightforward particles in part of
reported well the difficulty is always
knowing exactly how many particles went
in so this is a challenge we have and we
accomplish this task in by having a
reference counter to compare to so we
have a perfect reference you could say
and we have a concentration that's
evenly distributed between the perfect
reference and the counter we want to
test so these two instruments are
sampling exactly the same atmosphere of
precise particles and therefore we can
kind of get a sense more correctly that
we have concentration accounting
efficiency in comparing the two
instruments so we start out with a
traceable calibrated standard we have a
environment here represented by the blue
tub didn't that is a consistent
concentration of known size particle we
introduced that into the test and we say
well here we have in this example 0.5
micron particles and this particularly
is one that will give us a rating at 0.3
so we expect to see everything above 0.3
and larger and look at that
concentration of particles okay that's a
good start at least now we have a sense
of what the number should be in this
case this example mm and so based on
that then we say well now we want to
compare the other unit to it what do we
do so we start with this idea we have a
known concentration and we put that into
a particle counter whose got higher
sensitivity than what that concentration
is so we start out for example 0.5
micron challenge 0.3 micron setting we
should see everything that's there
notice though that that curve is not a
single spike it's a somewhat that's
generally a Gaussian or a curve that has
a distribution to it fairly tight if
it's got good resolution and but it is a
distribution it's not a absolute
spike you could say at 0.5 microns
because both it was variation both in
the challenge material and in the
perfect spheres that we send in there's
also some variation due to the
instrument by resolution we know what
that variation should be and so within
limits but when we actually take a
challenge in will get a very variability
there so then if we put two instruments
and sample simultaneously this
atmosphere that's well mixed we then
would see the mm value in the first
challenge we see a different number we
see a value of 1000 in the unit we're
testing why is that and is that correct
well yes it's correct because the
counter is designated under-21 501 to
report 50 percent of the challenge at
that particular threshold size of 0.5
micron where it's said plus or minus 20
percent that's the test why does that
occur well because the traceable
standard shows a value of a hundred
percent because its threshold is set way
down here at point three micron as an
example where as a threshold of the
Union under test four point five micron
is set right in the middle of that curve
so if we look at a typical Gaussian
curve and are looking at the peak of it
what we see is that threshold size and
greater gives us 50% and so again that's
the target of the test 50% plus or minus
20% for that most sensitive sides at
very low size a particular instrument is
capable of sampling that might be 0.1
micron that might be 0.3 might be 0.5
whatever it is it will be said at what's
known as the 50% point however in this
method of iso 21 5 or 1-4 there's
actually two tests for the age
accounting efficiency one is if you send
it in the particles that are right at
the very most sensitive threshold
see 50% well what if I said it like we
did the test one what if we give it a
little bit bigger particles somewhere
between one and a half to two times a
size okay and then say well here I'm
going to send in bigger particles I'm
gonna keep my threshold still at 0.5 as
an example I'm going to send in 0.75 to
one micron particle size particles and
will I see under per cinema
well that is that the challenge and the
designation there we should be able to
see ideally 100% plus or minus a small
amount in fact plus or minus 10% so
counting efficiency under 21 501
involves two steps size of particles
it's right at the threshold minimum
threshold capability of the counter and
asides it's one and a half to two times
and we should see 100% in that second
test one of the things about the current
revision discussion is what tests are
appropriate for various stages of a
particle counters life in its design in
its production in its lifetime of use
and those are different and so this is a
tentative discussion of what is
appropriate to use in the field and that
statement of calibration to test or the
calibration over the lifetime involves
fewer tests done in that time period
what we would call generally the
calibration time period versus when for
example a unit is first design it's much
more exhaustively tested as well as in
the initial production use of it
but over the lifetime an instrument just
a few of these tests are needed to
verify that it is continuing to operate
as designed so this is one of the
discussions is coming up in 21 501 so
basically is a summary 21 501 delivers
better compliance better accuracy
accounts over the lifetime of the
instrument and improved correlation of
counts over the between two different
two different instruments
so again just as a summary realize that
not all counters were design
- or continue to meet 21 501 - four
methods over their lifetime maybe
sometimes they weren't designed
correctly for this in mind or perhaps
they've been damaged or just aged over
time the light source for example the
laser has degraded over time and
therefore the counting efficiency test
fails also realize that the counters
this method applies both to counters
used for classification and for
monitoring ISO 21 501 - 4 itself is
under revision discretion - involved a
bit with that and I can say you know
again it's not going to be a major
radical change in the processes that are
involved it's just trying to make some
improvements and consistencies in that
method so that is it is used by various
industries it is practical and not too
difficult a test to execute not one that
cost extraordinary amount of money to
know that a given instrument the
particle counter continues to operate in
the way it should so basically the
fundamental task for most people and
looking at this requirement 421 501 is
simply to confirm that your current
instruments do meet the 21 501 and if
they don't start the process of setting
up replacements or getting to the point
where you do meet the standard if it at
a reasonable period of time the next
year or so so with that I'll say thank
you again for your attention and
interest and turn it back to judy for
any commentary and questions thank you
Joe for that informative presentation
it's time for Q&A if you have a question
you'd like to ask Joe please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen
and click on the send button well answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for let's get started our first
question is do you know the typical
pressure difference that has to exist to
maintain positive pressure in a clean
room
okay you know inherent in that question
hidden the question right is at this
statement that there's both negative and
positive pressure rooms sometimes use
negative pressure for containment
if it's a positive pressure room this
will depend sometimes on the industry
for example in GMP documents they talk
about a certain level of pressure for
high risk of critical areas being
maintained and this can vary slightly
between industries or between the types
of work to be done there is a lot of
discussion about this in the industry
right now because of the thinking about
energy cost it cost more to pressurize a
room so as you increase the pressure you
have more issues as you try to build
that up you certainly want to have a
pause enough pressure to keep particles
out and that tends to be you know 10 to
15 Pascal you know something in that
level is considered useful but you know
the current technologies and concerns
with energy probably going to allow that
to be a little bit lesser amount but
again it depends on the risk so I don't
know that there is a universal
differential pressure needed in some
cases right now you're beholden to two
let's say a GMP document and kind of
stuck with it you might say but just
realize that there is discussion going
on even amongst the ISO group within the
industry looking at energy cost and
trying to find a good level that helps
satisfy the needs of the process but
also is not necessarily just simply
based on historical levels that were
said many many years ago and we're not
necessarily concerned with energy cost
in ISO 1464 4-1 note section some
particle counters cannot be calibrated
through all of the required tests in ISO
21500 1-4 if this is the case record the
decision to use the counter in a test
report this is mean that the use of ISO
21 501
not dictated for the calibration of if
it is a PC it means it was a
consideration you might say put in by
the committee that changing everyone all
the particle counters used by a
particular customer or one point ticker
user or particular facility might be a
onerous financial cost to do instantly
so again not all counters were designed
or maintained to that what it does mean
though is you have to record that on the
document for your classification it will
show up as I didn't use an ISO 21 501 -
4 instrument that's going to tend to be
a flag to regulators in those industries
that you know your instrument is not
really up to perhaps snuff up to what
should be done and therefore the results
of the test are perhaps called into
question which generally with regulators
is not a good idea so you know the
direction here is trying to give a bit
of leeway you might say in the first
years of the you know implementation but
I know regulators are going to be
looking at these requirements and it's
something where if you put that on the
report it's probably going to be called
into question
so another wise way I have a contract
company come in and do my formal
classification each year so do I need to
still have my particle counters
calibrated to ISO 21 501 - for when I'm
only using them from monitoring um yes
you would
and again this goes back to the - to
document and its reference to 21 501 - 4
as as involved in monitoring and in some
ways it's you might almost say it's more
important in the reality because you
want to know that as you use that
instrument to evaluate for your process
week by week that your area continues to
meet that and again by using 21500 1-4
you have a very consistent method of
looking at the health of the instrument
each year or every six months so you
have higher assurance that the values
you're getting you know for your area as
you work day to day or week to week or
month to month taking those samples do
in fact meet your requirements for your
process so yes it's in the document for
monitoring and regardless is probably
good wisdom I would like to once again
thank Joe Pesci for his presentation do
you have any final comments
I think certainly to say that in the ISO
world we constantly look at evaluating
these standards we try to make them
appropriate for the industry or
industries that are involved we look for
suggestions information commentary of
course as we draft these ideally each
document gets reviewed every five years
for changes and technology or if it's
still appropriate or what might be
needed so for those who are using in the
documents we appreciate always input two
concerns challenges technologies that
might dictate better methods so I just
encourage people to work with the people
in their country or company who are
involved with standards and make
recommendations when they see fit so
that's certainly input appreciated last
comment would just be that although
these changes are notable you might say
they're not shouldn't be highly
significant there might be a few more
points needed to satisfy 14 644 or a
great ABCD designation but the purpose
again is to build confidence that that
zone or area meets the requirement
needed for that particular aspect and
risk is controlled well enough so
there's a
purpose behind it and hopefully we've
captured that well enough in the
documents so with that I will say thank
you for everyone's attention today well
thank you once again
I also like to thank our sponsor Pittman
culture Life Sciences for making today's
educational webcast possible this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
sheet' button at the bottom left corner
and follow the process to receive your
credits before I go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through January 13th 2017 you'll receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay we share that announcement with
your colleagues you may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye